[Music]  time travel  it's not a superpower  it's a  disability it's what's wrong with me  can i help you  [Music]  henry  sorry i i don't know claire  so we've  met them yes  [Music]  we just happened to each other  in the wrong order  any hobbies  i'm your future wife  your day  well  my three things i got good at to survive  the danger isn't the worst  christmas is the worst  there are days he keeps going back too i  can't control it  yeah i hate to be where she's not  [Music]  i'm always going and she can't follow  this is me changing the future  i have tried to change it trust me  you can't  [Music]  hi everyone the hell are you what does  he look like  [Music]  i love henry more than i could ever love  anyone else so then where is he  i don't have very long  nobody has very long  i think i'm going  no no no i love you  why is love  intensified by absence  [Music]  you